souvent champions ce soir avec jamel
debbouze
moi je joue pas je regarde jamais avec
et je tente et kherrata et gagner moi
ouais merci en tout cas
d'applaudissements jeux rompant avec
erika je n'ai jamais eu des blagues
natasha st pier
à chacun de ces pardons thierry ardisson
bon allez vous commencer recentrer les
facile facile jusqu'à le groupe anglais
ses deux premiers attention le premier
qui donne la bonne réponse qu'il a été
chanceux satisfaction en 65 000 réponses
mais là comme on a l'habitude de la voir
à moi série qui la magie respecte buzzer
claudiennes comédienne quelle comédienne
et chanteuse est la partenaire de sonny
bono pour ipod touch and go away
j'arrête de jouer mon jeu il est bon dit
comme non qu'est ce qu'ils sentent si
jamais regardé cette émission parce
qu'il vous faut damas à ne pas pas très
belle vidéo qu'il avait triché
non je sais pas j'ai dit qu'il avait
triché non je plaisante je veux tu vas
pas regarder où il avait regardé la
scène chanteurs noirs américains et les
los angeles ont senti seddiqui otis
redding la gdc blindtest chanteuse qui
est lauréate de l'eurovision 67
myriam non avec papa dans no strings la
chanteuse aux pieds nus sans déchirer
john est la vache à lait ou john l
allier la jambe
m
ouais toujours que c'est plus marrant
dans les loges
non mais il ya des gars laurent gerra
sèmassi stands et souhaitons super sympa
de pouce est mieux là bas qui arrive aux
[ __ ] le voit c'est sur la bouche
c'est un jugement c'est l'amour john
battelle halper salut que jamais
attention et g 10 ans se consoler grâce
en crevant génial duo mis six
interprètes bicis robinson en 68 time
and garfunkel
gagés nous sommes oui c'est là qu'elle
chanteur américain le créateur de in
nomine à 65 ennemis wilson pickett on
avait zéro alors là c'est plus dur
quelle est cette chanson quelle chanson
de carole king et gerry goffin rend
célèbre little et va en soit c'est comme
ça
jean cyril alors on joue pour de vrai
alors là celle-là c'est là les plus
anciens à la musique
combien de la musique parce que monsieur
ouais voilà celle là non en 65 à quel
chanteur doit-on la reprise de
guantanamera de groupe laisse arrive à
trouver leurs noms harry belafonte il a
chanté je pensais oui il a chanté je
pense j'ai gagné non non non quel
chanteur français on va dire chanter en
france je dis ah ça oui je suis je suis
déçu que gagne mon émission jamais un
titre
claude françois donne-t-il à la chanson
mais to love des everly bottes belles
belles belles comme le jet exactement 20
ans julien quel titre porte adaptation
de barber et baba bye bye lenin non
c'est moi c'est toi je le dis ce que tu
en penses que tu me dises étoilé pas de
problème
les baby baby baby dolls et je suis à
modérer islam récifs 62 chanteuse
française d'origine bulgare qui reprend
le site du lieutenant non comme un chat
et c'est bien ce entre le web
c'est un genre que ça a bien fini comme
çà y est celle là celle là pour la pour
la route 1 la dernière brian en plus que
michael keaton nul s'asseoir en 1961
déjà la date 61
quel chanteur reçoit son premier disque
d'or pour viens danser le twist adapté
de la swiss de gars de tché bi tché
coeur c'est johnny johnny hallyday les
amis
on pour être sûr de ne rien rater de nos
latitudes abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux